does weworks implosion pose a systemic
risk company went from a 47 billion
dollar valuation to near bankruptcy in
just six weeks it's been a kind of a
phenomenal story to watch me work is
facing a cash crunch at its current burn
rate of 700 million dollars a quarter
it's probably gonna run out of money by
the first half of next year how and what
is this company gonna do if it doesn't
hit the public market and raise that
money hi welcome to another cold fusion
video the idea of a modern-day tech
company is shrouded in glamor casual
dress cutting-edge tech and a
collaborative atmosphere which frees
workers from mundane pigeon-holed work
this dream is exactly what we work sells
to people we work rents out co-working
offices - freelancers small business
owners and even some tech giant's the
company was an exciting fast-growing
startup on course to issue an IPO in
September 2019 valued at 47 billion
dollars things were going great for we
work until people started looking into
the company and more importantly their
founder and CEO Adam Newman from a
failed IPO to a disgraced CEO let's take
a look at the story of work a premature
pseudo tech giant which could be falling
apart
right in front of our eyes
[Music]
co-working has been around since the 90s
and had been growing in popularity since
2005 riding on this wave we work was
founded in 2010 though what made the
company popular right from the start was
their ability to tap into the market and
sell an idea open spaces collaborative
areas it was hip and fresh it didn't
look or feel like a traditional office
they focused on community drawing from
their founders experiences of growing up
in communal living spaces they framed
themselves as a tech company employing
data analytics tools and other smart
tech to improve the efficiency of their
spaces this led to an understanding of
exactly how people use their spaces
where to build next and how the spaces
should look we work found themselves a
target market and grew quickly the
company received some big backing from
investors such as Goldman Sachs JP
Morgan and Softbank even Amazon invested
in we work this year in total we work
secured fourteen point two billion
dollars in funding since 2009 though low
interest rates made it easy for
investment firms to pump cash into
growing companies one of these cash
pumpers was master Yoshi son the CEO of
soft Bank he manages a one hundred
billion dollar vision Fund we've covered
son and his Softbank company in a
previous video his rags to riches story
is really amazing in itself and I'll
leave the link for that below son had
made perhaps one of the greatest
investments of all time just a few
decades earlier when he gave a young
Jack Ma 20 million dollars to fund
Alibaba in 2017 son famously met with
Adam for just 12 minutes before deciding
to invest 4.4 billion son had found a
new apprenticed in Adam Neiman and in
son Neiman had found a mentor but son's
belief in Newman while it gave way to
his rise may also have been part of the
reason for his adventure downfall
over the coming decades we work used
money from its investors to amass 847
locations across 123 cities globally in
fact we work with central London's
biggest office occupier and also the
biggest private office tenant in
Manhattan but Adam Newman had bigger
dreams for the company than just renting
office spaces rebranding as the wee
company along with we work is also we
live essentially renting furnished
apartment and more interestingly we grow
which in its own words is a quote
conscientious entrepreneurial school for
young children with tuition fees between
20 2014 2013 words quote committed to
elevating the collaborative
consciousness of the world and quote we
grow is run by a Rebecca Newman wife of
Adam Newman and cousin of Gwyneth
Paltrow the so called founding parents
testify about the school's intangible
strengths I see many schools that are
very established at the big issue with
those school is that they're behind we
grow is teaching the children how to
adapt to the rapidly changing world
around us Emma Aussie but all of this
apparent success had an air of doubt
around it we work has secured funding
they grew into a giant but they hadn't
made a profit yet nevertheless after
uber went public in May we work became
the most valuable venture-backed company
in the United States now it's not
uncommon for a tech company to take a
while to return a profit but we work
although it likes to think of itself as
a tech company really isn't we work is
effectively a landlord
they don't sell technology hardware or
software they simply rent office space
they use technology to make more
effective business decisions but these
days most companies do and therein lies
the main problem with we work how's the
landlord company supposed to make
explosive returns and growth like that
of a tech company
beneath the facade of a successful tech
company lay the true story a story of a
company he hadn't yet turned a profit
but was being hailed as a Titan of
industry and a founder who got drunk on
the allure of being a pioneer if you
have a business that's mission driven
you will attract the best people
if you attract the best people remember
this you have to treat them the way you
want to be treated you have to take care
of them I know today and I did not
understand this in the past that the
most important thing in our business and
in every business are the employees in
the people making it work every single
day one reason that investors began to
look critically a we work was that there
was an obvious and inherent risk with
the company's business model we work
engages in an average lease of 15 years
with a landowner this means that we work
pays a fixed amount each year for the
land to lease the company then charges
people to use the space
if occupancy is high or property prices
increase then we work makes money off
the space
however if occupancy dips too low or
property prices fall we work can't
charge as much yet they still have to
pay the agreed lease hence the company
would be bleeding money to counter this
we work as a company structure of
subsidiaries which holds specific leases
in different areas that way if one
subsidiary has to fail it doesn't
propagate to the rest of the business
but many people still believe that we
work wouldn't be able to sustain
themselves in the myths of another
financial crisis or similar crisis where
fewer people are willing to rent
co-working spaces and besides all of
this massive cracks have appeared in the
company
the cracks became apparent to investors
as we workers prepping for an IPO in
four September 2019 the problems all
started in January with Softbank a major
investor in we work they backpedaled on
a proposed 16 billion dollar stake in
the company reducing that figure to just
2 billion this was blamed on a dip in
soft banks share price but some people
were concerned the soft bank was
rethinking we work all together
so as we work began his IPO filings
investors were keen to see what all the
fuss was about during the process for
filing for an IPO a company is required
to disclose a lot of information to
potential investors this means
financials business models disclosures
among other things the company goes
quite literally from private to public
and this was where the suspicions of the
47 billion dollar valuation arose
internal documents from weworks IPO
filings revealed that it was losing more
than five thousand dollars per new
customer this was a terrible look for a
company as more details came out the
company's valley had dropped by nearly
80 percent just this year alone and then
he blamed the financial situation but
also there's many doubts about the
company's founder and CEO Adam Newman to
give you an idea of Adams character he
trademarks the word we then had the
company pay him 5.9 million dollars in
licensing fees the Sydney Morning Herald
has also called him the newest most
hated man in America you're in a
business where you're you're going out
and you're securing long-term leases
where you have a long term expenditure
and you have very short term revenue
obligations $650 a month and and the
criticism goes something like wait till
Adam sees a downturn how do you respond
to that what value do you drive by
actually going and telling the world
what works and what doesn't work about
another company that you have no access
to their numbers you probably don't
understand the business model but if
you're just gonna express an opinion
about something you might not know a lot
about especially if that person is pi
something from you don't do it Adam
Neiman moved to the United States in
2001 and after a time in the Israeli
Navy he studied business in New York his
business venture before founding wework
was a failed baby clothes company called
crawlers that may pants with knee pads
for crawling babies Adam Newman is an
interesting character he has the typical
confidence to dare to do anything the
attitude of any Silicon Valley founder
despite being from New York but Neumann
wasn't your typical startup founder in
many other ways as interest in the IPO
grew so did the list of reports of not
just about we work but about Newman
himself from his use of drugs and
alcohol to his tirades in the workplace
was as if Newman lived in an alternate
reality a reality
perhaps fed by those around him Ashton
Kutcher and Newman were close even
pitching a shark tank style idea to a TV
network but it was never picked up but
perhaps it was messy oshi son who gave
Newman an untouchable status in the tech
world son will proclaim that quote we
work is next to Alibaba unquote and also
telling Newman you need to think bigger
with the confidence of having such a
figure believe in you who else could
tell you otherwise
Newman wanted his staff to work hard and
play hard Adam said that he likes how
alcohol brings people together during
executive retreats extravagant cases of
110 dollar a bottle tequila were
reportedly always within reach it was
said that the drinking of these retreats
started in the morning in 2016 several
weeks after Neumann fired seven percent
of his staff he held a company-wide
meeting but not just any meeting after
telling the staff that the cuts were
necessary he brought out trays of
tequila shots and then brought in a
famous rapper from the group who Run DMC
to perform Niemann and some of his staff
danced while others stood around amused
according to friends and former
executives there was a case of Adam
Newman trying to smuggle cannabis into
Israel a country where it's very much
illegal and one trip on his private jet
to Israel with some friends upon landing
the flight crew found a stash inside a
cereal box
realizing that they'd been tricked into
international drug trafficking the pilot
and crew immediately flew back leaving
Newman stranded in Israel Adam Newman
also liked to smoke before meetings and
on private plane trips like many other
founders he's also not a fan of a suit
and tie he preferred to walk around the
office barefoot Newman would call a
personal trainer to visit him in the
office for a midday boxing session then
would continue about his day walking
around the office covered in sweat
speaking of his office he had a private
office with his own meditation room
complete would beat a whiteboard for his
free flowing ideas and a large
apparently photoshopped image of him
surfing but if all of that wasn't enough
Newman was also very impulsive on a
video call with his executive team
he ordered a company-wide ban on meat
leaving the team to scramble together to
figure out how to enforce the ban yet
former employees say that they've since
seen Newman eat meat himself
other times he proved to be a tyrant
raging through the office a former
employee testified quote no one wanted
to get in his way he even got berated or
humiliated or asked to do some
impossible tasks and quote one time he
called a meeting to demand the manager
responsible for buying a new coffee
machine without
his approval to step forward a number of
his close friends and family hold
executive positions within the company
sometimes according to an employee
they'll sit in on random meetings and
leave without saying a word there are
currently three lawsuits against the
company
one for age discrimination and two for
sexual harassment but aside from the
parties and non-traditional approaches
it was Newman's financial dealings that
have the investors skeptical he
collected rent on properties that he
owned himself from we work somewhat of a
conflict of interest
he also borrowed hundreds of millions of
dollars from we work at interest rates
below 1% he purchased a sixty million
dollar company jet despite the company
losing one point six billion dollars
that year he also sold hundreds of
millions of dollars of company shares
over the years it seemed like he didn't
have any confidence or care about the
company's future as report after report
came out newman must have known that he
wasn't damage control investors were
unanimously slamming we work as a bad
investment and reports about Nieman's
character began filling the headlines
the IPO was put on indefinite pause and
Newman was forced out of the company and
had to resign as CEO that sixty million
dollar jet that Newman bought also has
to go shocking to many Neiman will still
walk away from the company he founded
with 1.7 billion dollars while many
thousands of the company may lose their
jobs also in the end
Softbank reportedly would have invested
fifteen point four billion dollars in
the we work disaster more than the gross
domestic product of Jamaica well I still
want to invest more and I want to
increase some of my investors as muscle
sure you get too excited and too much
concentration into one company don't go
too far two months
[Music]
we work isn't a tough situation the
business model is risky it hasn't turned
a profit and investors just forced out
the company's charismatic yet reckless
founder and CEO the company is fast
running out of cash and in dire need of
investors this resulted in a five
billion dollar investment from Softbank
in October 2019 and now Softbank has
control of the company for we work to
restart their efforts towards an IPO may
prove to be just as difficult as fixing
the damage Nieman has caused it's a very
real possibility that we work could be
heading to bankruptcy court that would
be a catastrophe of epic proportions in
pure dollar terms the fall of weworks
valuation is right up there with all
time value destruction champions like
Enron
WorldCom and Lehman Brothers not only
this but he could shake the very
foundations of the concept of investing
in a unicorn company these pin vestment
banks should have known better we've
seen people fall victims to these
charismatic types before this house of
cards was coming down this is a failure
in misunderstanding what the marketplace
is find me another example of creating a
company that you know loses fifty cents
out of every dollar of revenue and in
explain to me how that works he needs to
think about what's best for the company
at this point and I don't think it
includes him it hasn't been a good time
uber lyft slack Dropbox and beyond mate
are all trading below their IPO prices
Fitbit traded $50 a share after its IPO
in 2015 but when it was recently bought
by Google it was only just seven dollars
a share but what makes the we work
disaster so interesting is that it never
made it to the public markets it seems
that people are no longer willing to buy
the hype of IPOs
of course the number one casualty of the
wework disaster has been messy oh she
son the chairman of Softbank he's lost
billions but not only that his
reputation as an expert investor may be
damaged and finally in all of this
there's one major cloud hanging over we
work and it's something outside of their
control the health of the financial
markets themselves to explain it briefly
there's a problem in the repo market the
repo market is basically the mechanism
that keeps the whole financial system
running on a daily basis on Tuesday
September 17th 2019 there was a
catastrophic failure of some kind until
this day no one in the public can really
be sure what it was but as a result up
to a hundred billion dollars a day has
been pumped into the system to keep it
going if you look at the balance
statements of the New York Fed
mortgage-backed securities made up a
significant portion of these funds it
would seem like there's a problem in the
real estate sector once again if this is
indeed the case another real estate
downturn would obliterate we work in the
blink of an eye that model has gone
bankrupt multiple times before what
happens is you arbitrage the risk of
short term leases with long term debt so
you go buy a building and put debt on it
when rates go up and there's an economic
slowdown is in the recession you go
bankrupt so no I won't be investing in
that if you invest in that you should
realize that's another money loser right
now no matter the outcome it doesn't
look good for we work as it stands time
will tell with the wework story so there
you have it that's the story of how a
company went from being valued 47
billion dollars and hailed as a start-up
poster boy to having to cancel an IPO
and forcing their erratic CEO out and
it's a story that could cause a shift in
how we view IPOs that's the story of we
work so far
next week in the next episode of cold
fusion we'll be taking a look at the
popular app tic toc you might not know
but it's now the number one social media
app in the world and the company behind
it is the most valuable private company
on the planet if you want to see all of
that and more in the next episode
definitely subscribe so you don't miss
it so thanks for watching I really
appreciate it don't forget to check out
the cold fusion podcast and also follow
me on Instagram and Twitter anyway this
has been - gogo and you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll catch you again
soon for the next video cheers guys have
a good one
cold fusion is he thinking
[Music]
[Applause]